[Music]
agriculture is the main source of
livelihood in the rural areas of india
in maharashtra more than half of the
population is dependent and engaged in
agriculture the state produces twelve
percent of india's total fruit
production
and seven percent of the country's total
vegetable production
despite these outputs farmers are unable
to benefit fully from horticulture as
they lack access to adequate
post-harvest facilities finance and
equipment
women form a large part of agricultural
labor force and play a significant role
in production and post-harvest
processing
yet
they face several challenges
sadly they lack empowerment
representation participation land
ownership employment opportunities
productivity and training
to help farmers including women overcome
these challenges the asian development
bank and maharashtra department of
marketing and textiles is initiating the
maharashtra agribusiness network project
to support the development of the
horticulture
maharashtra agro business network
project we call it magnet which is
going to be implemented with the
financial assistance of asian
development bank manila by the
department of agriculture marketing and
cooperation government of maharashtra
is a project which is totally aligned
with government of maharashtra's
[Music]
long-term vision it's called vision
2013. under this vision
2013 maharashtra wishes to
enhance the farm income
double it
and also achieve agricultural growth
rate
up to five percent per annum
under this vision we wish to improve the
quality and yield of horticulture and
florida culture crops we wish to create
quality infrastructure for storage and
processing
want to extend
agriculture credit to all the farmers
especially horticulture farmers
the project aims to improve farmers
income increase productivity and reduces
losses in horticulture production
farmers especially women will be trained
on handling crops after harvest selling
their produce and new agricultural
practices and technologies
farmer organization and value chain
operators such as wholesalers and
retailers will have access to grants and
loans
to develop post-harvest facilities and
raise capital to improve their market
activities
the project will upgrade existing
post-harvest facilities and establish
new ones to maintain the quality and
freshness of the crops
output one of the project
focuses on capacity building of pharma
producer organizations
output 2 of the project focuses on
enhancing
access to finance
this would be achieved by providing
matching grant and financial
intermediate loan output 3 of the
project focuses on improvement and
development of 16
existing facilities of mars state
agriculture marketing board
and also development of three new
facilities
the project will work as value chain
accelerator to offer crop based support
to develop fbos and market their
products with higher brand values
magnet project directly targets 200
farmer
organizations and 100 value chain
operate
to enhance their capacities and provide
access to finance
the project will create
10 000 jobs benefiting women and
vulnerable groups and increase pharma
producer organization's annual profits
by 10 percent
adb will demonstrate
value addition in exemplary rural and
agricultural transformation in
maharashtra and magnet is an integral
part of adb's holistic project
addressing rural and intercity
connectivity
efficient energy supply and sustainable
shoreline management